Hello. Welcome to Smart List. I am Jason Bateman, one of the less smart hosts. Even less smart is Will Arnett and truly dumb is Sean Hayes. We each have invited, well, one of us invites a guest per week. The other two don't know who that person is. Some of it's going to be funny. Hopefully you won't cry and hopefully you learn a little something. So let's get started. Hey fellas. Hey guys. What's going on? Great to see you guys. It's great to see you too. Did you work out this morning? You look like you've shed a little water weight. Okay. You know what? Actually, I have. And yesterday, Sean, Jason and I were hanging out and he made a comment that somehow I look like I'm holding water. And do I look
你好。欢迎来到《Smart List》。我是杰森·贝特曼，我是几位主持人中不太聪明的那一个。威尔·阿奈特更不聪明，而肖恩·海耶斯则是真的笨。我们每个人都邀请了，好吧，是我们每周轮流邀请一位嘉宾。另外两个人不知道嘉宾是谁。其中一些内容会很有趣。希望你不会哭，也希望你能学到一点东西。那么我们开始吧。嘿，伙计们。嘿，伙计们。怎么了？很高兴见到你们。我也很高兴见到你们。你今天早上锻炼了吗？你看上去好像减掉了一些水分。好吧。你知道吗？其实，我确实锻炼了。昨天，肖恩、杰森和我在一起玩，他评论说我看起来好像有点水肿。我看起来
like I'm holding water? Be honest. No. Well, you look great. You're the father of four, 15, three, six, three and a half kids, three and a half kids. Wait, who owns the other half? I was going to say this the other day. You said something. I forget what show was, but one of our shows, you said you've got like 17. Have you ever noticed anytime people make up a number that they're trying to say like, you've got 17 kids. You always, people always say 17. Yeah. Have you ever noticed that? Yes. And I notice it because 17 is actually my lucky number. And Jason knows this for a fact. Speaking of 17, this guy, now, you know, one, this is true. Will has a custom made golf balls to put the number 17 on his
像水肿了吗？说实话。没有。嗯，你看起来很棒。你是四个孩子的父亲，15岁、3岁、6岁，还有三个半孩子，三个半孩子。等等，谁拥有另外那一半？我前几天就想说这个。你说了些什么。我忘了是哪个节目了，但在我们的一档节目里，你说你有17个孩子。你有没有注意到，每当人们编造一个数字时，他们总是想说，比如，你有17个孩子。你总是，人们总是说17。是的。你有没有注意到这一点？是的。我注意到了，因为17实际上是我的幸运数字。杰森对此心知肚明。说到17，这家伙，现在，你知道，第一，这是真的。威尔有定制的高尔夫球，上面印着数字17
golf ball. That's a true story. Because he's a Wendell Clark fan. Greatest hockey player. So when this guy, remember low score is when you're playing golf, you want to not swing, you know, so many times low score wins. He looks down at the ball before every swing and he's looking at a 17. That's my number. This is why this way you're a terrible golfer. Put a one down there. I grew up and I love, I love Wendell Clark, but of course Shani, our friend Shani is also, you know, one of the all time greats. I don't, because I feel like Shani sometimes feels like, wow, you really love Wendell and there's not enough love. What was Shani hands? Shani was in the hall of fame. What was his number though?
高尔夫球。这是个真实的故事。因为他是温德尔·克拉克的粉丝。最伟大的冰球运动员。所以当这家伙，记住打高尔夫球时分数越低越好，你不想挥杆，你知道，太多次，低分获胜。他在每次挥杆前都会低头看球，他看到的是17。那是我的号码。这就是为什么你是个糟糕的高尔夫球手。放个1在下面吧。我长大了，我爱，我爱温德尔·克拉克，但当然，肖尼，我们的朋友肖尼也是，你知道，史上最伟大的人之一。我不，因为我觉得肖尼有时会觉得，哇，你真的很爱温德尔，而对他的爱不够。肖尼·汉兹是什么？肖尼进了名人堂。不过他的号码是多少？
Shani is 14. Oh, that's a, that's a better score than 17. Save you three strokes on the next hole. Anyway, thank you. Thank you for, I guess this all comes back to thank you. I do, I did work out this morning. Guys, here's, here's what I love about our little show. In addition to bringing on friends and getting to know something about them that we don't already know, we get to bring on people we've always wanted to meet. And for some reason they say yes. And I don't know why. Are you segueing into the intro right now? Yeah, this is it. This is one of the all time great segues. Thank you. Yeah, it was subtle. And it started with guys. Yeah, but I've always wanted to meet this guy. He was born in Barquisimeto,
肖尼是14号。哦，那是个比17更好的分数。下一洞能帮你省三杆。总之，谢谢。谢谢你，我想这一切都归结为谢谢。我确实，我今天早上锻炼了。伙计们，这就是我喜欢我们这个小节目的原因。除了邀请朋友并了解一些我们还不知道的关于他们的事情之外，我们还能邀请我们一直想见的人。出于某种原因，他们答应了。我不知道为什么。你现在是在过渡到开场白吗？是的，就是这样。这是史上最伟大的过渡之一。谢谢。是的，很微妙。而且它是从“伙计们”开始的。是的，但我一直想见这个人。他出生在巴基西梅托，
Venezuela. And he got his own star in the Hollywood Walk of Fame just last year for his advocacy of the arts. He is now, this is going to give it away, the artistic director of the LA Philharmonic. And besides receiving a billion awards for being the world's most awesome conductor, he conducted, get this, this is when I kind of perked up. He conducted the score for Star Wars, The Force Awakens. And he also conducted the upcoming Steven Spielberg adaptation of West Side Story. Happens to be my favorite musical. And there's a million other things we're going to talk about. Please welcome the unbelievable Gustavo Dutamal. Wow. Hello. I am absolutely for. Hello. I was having such a fun here listening to you. My God. Oh my God. You
委内瑞拉。去年他因为对艺术的倡导而在好莱坞星光大道上拥有了自己的星星。他现在是，这会泄露身份，洛杉矶爱乐乐团的艺术总监。除了因为成为世界上最棒的指挥家而获得十亿个奖项外，他还指挥了，听着，这是我开始振作的时候。他指挥了《星球大战：原力觉醒》的配乐。他还指挥了即将上映的史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格改编的《西区故事》。碰巧是我最喜欢的音乐剧。还有一百万其他事情我们要谈。请欢迎令人难以置信的古斯塔沃·杜达梅尔。哇。你好。我绝对是。你好。我在这里听你们说话真是太开心了。天哪。天哪。你
know, Sean, I have to say, so Gustavo, I hesitate even calling you by your first name. I feel like Gustavo. I know, show some respect. Mr. Dutamal. Sean, because Sean and I share a deep, deep love for classical music. And I have been fantasizing like, God, if I, if I could somehow book Gustavo Dutamal, it would blow Sean's mind. I can't believe you have Gustavo Dutamal. No, but it's such a pleasure to be with you. Thank you so much for joining us. Who named you Gustavo? Like, which one of your parents are like, I, I know Gustavo. It's because a poet, you know, called Gustavo Adolfo Becker, you know, Spanish poet. And, and, and he's very famous in the, in the Spanish, you know, literature and all of that. So it wasn't a family name or anything? No, I'm the first Gustavo,
知道，肖恩，我不得不说，古斯塔沃，我甚至犹豫要不要直呼你的名字。我觉得古斯塔沃。我知道，表示尊重。杜达梅尔先生。肖恩，因为肖恩和我对古典音乐有着深沉的爱。我一直在幻想，天哪，如果我，如果我能以某种方式预约到古斯塔沃·杜达梅尔，那一定会让肖恩大吃一惊。我不敢相信你请到了古斯塔沃·杜达梅尔。不，但能和你在一起真是太荣幸了。非常感谢你加入我们。谁给你取名古斯塔沃？就像，你的父母中哪一位说，我，我知道古斯塔沃。是因为一位诗人，你知道，叫古斯塔沃·阿道夫·贝克尔，你知道，西班牙诗人。而且，而且，他在西班牙，你知道，文学界等等非常有名。所以这不是家族名字什么的？不，我是第一个古斯塔沃，
you know, Gustavo the first. What do they call you for short? Does anybody call you Gus? Oh, but they don't know. They call me in different ways, but they, when they are angry, they call me Gustavo Adolfo, of course, you know, but generally, my little one, Michiquito, exactly my, my little one, then my, my grandmother, my mother, they call me like that. So, but I'm, I'm Gustavo, Gus, some people call me Gus. Do you have, wait, do you have brothers and sisters that get angry and call you that? Well, I have a sister that is the same age of my son, you know, so she's like my daughter. Wow. So yes, I was an only child for, for 30 years. Oh, wow. And, and I have a beautiful daughter. Wow. Oh, wow. That's so great. And do you live here in Los Angeles? You must.
你知道，古斯塔沃一世。他们简称你什么？有人叫你格斯吗？哦，但他们不知道。他们用不同的方式叫我，但是他们，当他们生气时，他们叫我古斯塔沃·阿道夫，当然，你知道，但通常，我的小家伙，Michiquito，正是我的，我的小家伙，然后我的祖母，我的母亲，他们这样叫我。所以，但我，我是古斯塔沃，格斯，有些人叫我格斯。你有，等等，你有兄弟姐妹生气时这样叫你吗？嗯，我有一个和我儿子同岁的妹妹，你知道，所以她就像我的女儿。哇。所以是的，我做了30年的独生子。哦，哇。而且，而且我有一个漂亮的女儿。哇。哦，哇。那太棒了。你住在洛杉矶吗？你一定住在这里。
I live in Los Angeles. Yes. I, you know, before the COVID thing, I was traveling, you know, nonstop around the world, even like, since I married four years ago, around four years ago, I stopped traveling so much, but, but I'm traveling all the time. But I, I, I can call Los Angeles a home, you know. So right now you would be doing the portion of the season at the Hollywood Bowl. Yes. But obviously that is, is not happening. So are you, have you been, I guess you can't really be traveling either. So you taking just some home time and hanging out with your, your wife and kid? Yes. Yes. It, you know, all of these complexities, I see as opportunities. And for me, you know, being traveling, being, being working in a very speed and a very fast speed,
我住在洛杉矶。是的。我，你知道，在新冠疫情之前，我一直在旅行，你知道，不停地环游世界，甚至像，自从我四年前结婚以来，大约四年前，我停止了那么多旅行，但是，但我一直在旅行。但是，我，我可以称洛杉矶为家，你知道。所以现在你本应该在好莱坞露天剧场进行演出季的部分演出。是的，但显然那没有发生。所以你，我想你也不能真的去旅行了？所以你只是花点时间在家，和你的妻子和孩子待在一起？是的。是的。你知道，所有这些复杂的情况，我将其视为机会。对我来说，你知道，一直在旅行，一直在以非常快的速度工作，
you know, I always say that we were leaving before the quarantine a prestissimo tempo that is very fast, you know. And now we go to an andante moderato. We can say walking. Exactly. I think Sean, let him finish. Sorry. And, and, and I think for the next chapter, you know, after all of this past, I believe I want to leave, you know, an alegro calmo, you know, I don't want to get back, you know, to, to the same amount of, you know, things, you know, craziness. Yes. Because I, you always go, go, go, go. I can't imagine with your energy and always, you know, doing everything, it seems that this quarantine, this downtime, I just imagine you would go crazy. Like, how do you feel? No, no. Well, I'm crazy because I cannot move in front of the orchestra, you know, that,
你知道，我总是说我们在隔离之前过着一种极快板（prestissimo tempo）的生活，非常快，你知道。现在我们变成了行板（andante moderato）。我们可以说是走路。正是如此。我想肖恩，让他说完。抱歉。而且，而且我认为对于下一章，你知道，在这一切过去之后，我相信我想过一种平静的快板（alegro calmo），你知道，我不想回到，你知道，同样数量的，你知道，事情，你知道，疯狂。是的。因为你总是去，去，去，去。我无法想象以你的精力和总是，你知道，做所有事情，似乎这次隔离，这段停工期，我只是想象你会疯掉。你感觉如何？不，不。嗯，我疯了，因为我不能在管弦乐队面前移动，你知道，那，
you know, I need that exercise. But I think, you know, the work of a conductor is a lot about reflection, you know, the interpretation, what you want to make from the notes that you are showing to the orchestra in a way, you know, with, with your movements and all of that. And, and it has been a great time for me to go deeply in a lot of things that I was doing, not the things that I will do, but things that I was doing. I think that it has been the process for me to go to, to other levels of the things that I do generally. And, you know, it comes from simplicity, you know, I'm rereading a lot of books, I'm reading new books. I have learned about myself a lot of things. I can cook really well. I can, I can clean, you know, I can.
你知道，我需要那种锻炼。但我认为，你知道，指挥的工作很大程度上是关于反思，你知道，诠释，你想从你以某种方式向管弦乐队展示的音符中创造什么，你知道，用你的动作等等。对我来说，这是一个深入研究我正在做的事情的好时机，不是我将要做的事情，而是我正在做的事情。我认为这对我来说是一个进入我通常所做事情的其他层面的过程。而且，你知道，它来自简单，你知道，我正在重读很多书，我正在读新书。我对自己学到了很多东西。我可以做得一手好菜。我可以，我可以打扫，你知道，我可以。
I've been reading a lot to actually recently in all seriousness, and I was reading, there are a lot of parallels between wartime and what we're going through right now. And I was reading about a book about, not necessarily about the World War II, but about how people lived in Europe during that time. And it wasn't as much a focus on the war itself, but about the people who were living there on either side and how similar it is. Of course, it's not, there's not the same, but sort of the mentality that was going on. And that's sort of the feelings that people were feeling were very, very similar. A hopelessness. Yeah. And I was thinking about what you said, Gustavo, it's great that you said that like a lot of reflection in, and as a conductor,
我最近确实读了很多书，说实话，我正在读，战时和我们现在正在经历的事情之间有很多相似之处。我正在读一本关于，不一定是关于第二次世界大战，而是关于人们在那个时期在欧洲是如何生活的。重点不在于战争本身，而在于生活在那里的双方的人们，以及它是多么相似。当然，它不是，它不完全一样，但那种正在发生的心态。那种人们感受到的感觉是非常，非常相似的。一种绝望。是的。我在想你说的，古斯塔沃，你说得很好，就像很多反思，而且作为一名指挥，
it's a lot about reflection. And that in this time, it has forced a lot of us to reflect on how we live our lives and what is important to us. I've been doing the same thing. And speaking of World War II, reminds me of a great Churchill quote that I've been thinking a lot about in this time, which is, never let a good crisis go to waste. And that's how that's been my, I love that. My mindset lately has been, yeah, just I got to, in this time, use this, what can I take out of it? And so you thought, well, let's start with the tan, right? So let's just try to get my skin looking as healthy as possible. You know, Jason, it's called the Quarantine. It seems like even since last week that maybe, did you fall asleep inside the bed?
这很大程度上是关于反思。而且在这个时候，它迫使我们许多人反思我们如何生活以及什么对我们重要。我也一直在做同样的事情。说到第二次世界大战，让我想起了一句伟大的丘吉尔名言，我在这段时间里一直在思考，那就是，永远不要浪费一场好的危机。这就是我的，我喜欢那个。我最近的心态是，是的，我必须，在这段时间里，利用这个，我能从中得到什么？所以你想，好吧，让我们从晒黑开始，对吧？所以让我们试着让我的皮肤看起来尽可能健康。你知道，杰森，这叫隔离。看起来甚至从上周开始，也许，你是在床上睡着了吗？
What happened was the nozzle broke. I mean, the sun just follows you. The nozzle broke on the mechanister and it all came out at once. You follow the sun around the planet, right? Because that's not a color you can get just during day hours in our country. No, I had them build me a special plane that's a convertible, convertible jet. So Gustavo, you know, a lot of people think that, I remember being a kid, like thinking, like watching conductors going, well, how hard could it be? They just wave their arms around and, you know, like the orchestra knows the notes to play and where to come in, but there's obviously a billion things to, you know, to it that's ridiculous. So explain how you shape a piece as the leader of the band, you know, because by the way,
发生的事情是喷嘴坏了。我的意思是，太阳只是跟着你。美黑机上的喷嘴坏了，它一下子全出来了。你跟着太阳绕着地球转，对吧？因为那不是你在我们国家的白天能得到的颜色。不，我让他们给我造了一架特殊的飞机，那是敞篷的，敞篷喷气机。所以古斯塔沃，你知道，很多人认为，我记得小时候，就像想，看着指挥们说，这能有多难？他们只是挥舞着手臂，你知道，就像管弦乐队知道要演奏的音符和在哪里进入，但显然有十亿件事，你知道，这太荒谬了。所以解释一下你作为乐队的领导者是如何塑造一首乐曲的，你知道，因为顺便说一句，
don't your arms ever get tired from holding them up that long? Because the shoulders on them are fantastic. Because I did some conducting in college and I thought that was going to be what I was going to do with my life, but all my gestures in our movements are so gigantic. People just looked like I was a crazy person. They looked at me like I was insane. And no, yes, it's, of course, it's more than the movements, for sure. Right. You know. But don't you see movies where people play conductors and they're just kind of like, they're just really bad at it. Yeah, but you know, I think every movement has to reflect, you know, the music. It has to shape the music that you are conducting and it shape different things. It shape the volume,
你的手臂举那么久不会累吗？因为他们的肩膀太棒了。因为我在大学里做过一些指挥，我以为那会是我一生要做的事情，但我所有的手势和动作都太巨大了。人们只是觉得我像个疯子。他们看着我，好像我疯了。而且不，是的，当然，这不仅仅是动作，肯定的。对吧。你知道。但你没看过电影里人们扮演指挥家，他们只是有点像，他们真的很不擅长吗？是的，但你知道，我认为每一个动作都必须反映，你知道，音乐。它必须塑造你正在指挥的音乐，它塑造不同的东西。它塑造音量，
the tempo, how fast, how slow, these kind of different things. But I believe our work is a lot, as we were talking, reflection, you know, it's a lot of about a philosophical point of view of an interpretation. Imagine to interpret Beethoven's symphony that have been playing, you know, for the last 200 years, you know, in different kind of styles, you know, and then you arrive to an orchestra that have played a thousand of times also. And with the great conductors, and then you arrive with a new idea, how to convince them of that idea that makes sense, you know, musically, it makes sense artistically. And it's a lot of also about psychology. I think the most beautiful process is the rehearsal process. Yeah, when you are preparing something, if you have the
节奏，多快，多慢，这些不同的东西。但我相信我们的工作很大程度上，正如我们所谈到的，反思，你知道，这是关于诠释的哲学观点。想象一下诠释贝多芬的交响曲，它已经在过去200年里，你知道，以不同的风格演奏，你知道，然后你来到一个也演奏过一千次的管弦乐队。而且有伟大的指挥家，然后你带着一个新想法来到这里，如何说服他们那个想法是有道理的，你知道，在音乐上，在艺术上是有道理的。而且这很大程度上也是关于心理学。我认为最美丽的过程是排练过程。是的，当你准备某件事时，如果你有
chance to go to a rehearsal because people see, you know, the performance and but the process is really interesting with 100 people in front of you. And now you are arriving at 10 o'clock in the morning, and then you have 100 people there, you know, with different realities, you know. Yeah, yeah. And then you want to you want to inspire them, you want to to convince them that there are other 1000 ways to interpret that music that they have played a lot of times before. So it's a beautiful process. It's a it's an invisible transformation. Sometimes you cannot see and you have to play a lot with the energy of the people, you know, from the podium where you are, I can see all the phases, you know, and you can see, you know, this guy have a problem, this lady, you know,
机会去参加排练，因为人们看到，你知道，演出，但这个过程在100人面前真的很有趣。现在你早上10点到达，然后你有100人在那里，你知道，有着不同的现实，你知道。是的，是的。然后你想，你想激励他们，你想说服他们，除了他们之前演奏过很多次的那种方式外，还有其他1000种方式来诠释那段音乐。所以这是一个美丽的过程。这是一个，这是一个无形的转变。有时你看不见，你必须用人们的能量玩很多，你知道，从你所在的指挥台上，我可以看到所有的面孔，你知道，你可以看到，你知道，这家伙有问题，这位女士，你知道，
is ultra happy, this one is and you have to put all of that energy in one box, you know, and take that and put more even more there. So right, it's a lot about psychology, philosophy. And that is the thing, you know, it's not only to it's fun, you know, I think with the time and sorry that I speak too much. No, no, my God, I can listen to you all day. But I think I was very super and in the way as I was conducting for when I was a young musician until now, you see an evolution in the way of how because maybe some movements I don't need right now to do as before to have the same energy, but it's part of an evolution. And yes, my arms, I have to say, are trained to be moving all the time. But yes, yeah. So for a listener who has never been to
超级开心，这个是，你必须把所有的能量放在一个盒子里，你知道，拿走那个，并在那里投入更多。所以对，这很大程度上是关于心理学，哲学。这就是那件事，你知道，这不仅仅是，这很有趣，你知道，我认为随着时间的推移，抱歉我说了太多。不，不，天哪，我可以整天听你说话。但我认为我在年轻时指挥时是非常超级的，直到现在，你看到了演变的，因为也许有些动作我现在不需要像以前那样做就能获得同样的能量，但这是演变的一部分。而且是的，我的手臂，我不得不说，受过训练，一直在移动。但是是的，是的。所以对于一个从未去过
see an orchestra play, but has been to many different rock concerts. Okay, so if you go to a rock show, and you hope that band plays the song that you know that you love, and they start playing it, but then they do it in a way that's completely different than what you're used to on the record or on the radio. Now, if you go to see you conduct, you know, the LA Phil or whatever, and let's say Beethoven's fourth piano cacheros are my favorite. So if you started conducting that and you started playing that at a tempo that is completely different than what I'm used to hearing, how much can you change what is on the sheet? What is acceptable? What is appropriate? What did Beethoven assume future conductors were going to do? Very, very interesting question, really.
看管弦乐队演奏，但去过许多不同摇滚音乐会的听众来说。好吧，如果你去参加摇滚演出，你希望乐队演奏你知道你喜欢的歌，他们开始演奏了，但他们演奏的方式和你习惯的唱片或广播里的完全不同。现在，如果你去看你指挥，你知道，洛杉矶爱乐乐团或其他什么，假设贝多芬的第四钢琴协奏曲是我最喜欢的。所以如果你开始指挥那个，并且你开始以一种完全不同于我习惯听到的节奏演奏那个，你可以改变乐谱上的多少？什么是可以接受的？什么是合适的？贝多芬假设未来的指挥家会做什么？非常，非常有趣的问题，真的。
It cannot be a capriccio. It cannot be an improvisation, you know, and especially if you are in front of musicians that they have their knowledge about what they are doing, you know, you cannot get and be crazy there in front of them and improvise and know everything have to be very well prepared. Although I have to say that since Beethoven premiered his concertos, let's talk about the Eroica Symphony, for example. The Eroica Symphony that is one of his, you know, main master pieces and is that one that he wrote for Napoleon and then he changed, you know, because he got angry with Napoleon because the ideals didn't drop his hand on. And then he premiered that, you know, with few musicians in a very small room. It was only one double bass, I think it was only one cello.
它不能是随想曲（capriccio）。它不能是即兴创作，你知道，特别是如果你面对的是对他们正在做的事情有了解的音乐家，你知道，你不能在他们面前变得疯狂并即兴创作，而且一切都必须准备得非常好。虽然我不得不说，自从贝多芬首演他的协奏曲以来，让我们谈谈《英雄交响曲》，例如。《英雄交响曲》是他，你知道，主要杰作之一，是他为拿破仑写的，然后他改变了，你知道，因为他生拿破仑的气，因为理想没有……然后他首演了那个，你知道，在一个小房间里只有几个音乐家。只有一个低音提琴，我想只有一个大提琴。
Imagine we play the Eroica now with eight double basses, ten cellos, we do, we double the winds, you know, I think the music has a dimension where you can play with some things. But note, you cannot change for sure, you know, you can change only the things that are flexible in the discourse, I don't know how to say, in the creation of the composer. Is that like tempo or the way you attack those notes or like how? Everything, it can be everything. But everything is in the music, I have to say. But in Beethoven, for example, he writes, for me, is very special because he was dead, you know, he was not allowed to listen to his music, you know, at the end of his life. Was that after the eighth symphony, did it go away completely? Exactly, exactly. He was losing,
想象一下我们现在用八把低音提琴，十把大提琴演奏《英雄交响曲》，我们做，我们加倍管乐，你知道，我认为音乐有一种维度，你可以玩一些东西。但注意，你当然不能改变，你知道，你只能改变作曲家创作中灵活的东西，我不知道怎么说。那是像节奏还是你攻击那些音符的方式或者像怎么？一切，它可以是一切。但一切都在音乐里，我不得不说。但在贝多芬，例如，他写道，对我来说，是非常特别的，因为他死了，你知道，他不被允许听他的音乐，你知道，在他生命的尽头。那是第八交响曲之后，它完全消失了吗？正是，正是。他正在失去，
he was losing already when he wrote the fifth, he was, you know, he was listening really bad. You know that one well, because exactly. And then when he goes, when you arrive to the ninth, sorry, it's Sean insulted me. It's okay. No, I didn't. I'm just cutting up speed. I'm getting you. Listen, my question, sorry, sorry to cut you off, Gustavo. No, no, don't worry. But just with Beethoven, did you believe the chemistry between Bonnie Hunt and Charles Groden because I didn't? No, Will, we're talking about the music here, not the dog film. Not Beethoven, the movie, not the dog film. Got it. I'm back on track. Not the 1992 movie. No, no, no, no. Talk about the composer, yeah. Got it, got it.
他写第五交响曲时已经在失去了，他，你知道，他听得很差。你知道那个很好，因为正是。然后当他去，当你到达第九交响曲时，抱歉，是肖恩侮辱了我。没关系。不，我没有。我只是在加快速度。我在捉弄你。听着，我的问题，抱歉，抱歉打断你，古斯塔沃。不，不，别担心。但只是关于贝多芬，你相信邦妮·亨特和查尔斯·格罗丁之间的化学反应吗？因为我不相信。不，威尔，我们在谈论这里的音乐，不是那部狗电影。不是贝多芬，那部电影，不是那部狗电影。明白了。我回到正轨了。不是1992年的电影。不，不，不，不。谈谈作曲家，是的。明白了，明白了。
To that point, Gustavo, you know, I studied piano at five years old. I started taking lessons and studying music and I started writing music. I thought I started conducting in college and I thought I was going to do all that stuff. But the anxiety to your point of having to hit those notes exactly as they're written, because you cannot improvise, you know, the notes are the notes. And so I did all these competitions and the pressure and the stress and the anxiety of having to do that. I was like, this isn't fun. Like it's not fun to hit the wrong notes because you hit one wrong note, everybody can tell. But in comedy or like stand up, if it's not going great, you can kind of, you know, massage it to your... And it's kind of incumbent upon you to one of the
说到这一点，古斯塔沃，你知道，我五岁时学习钢琴。我开始上课和学习音乐，我开始写音乐。我以为我在大学里开始指挥，我以为我会做所有那些事情。但那种必须完全按照书面要求击中那些音符的焦虑，因为你不能即兴创作，你知道，音符就是音符。所以我参加了所有这些比赛，那种必须那样做的压力、压力和焦虑。我就想，这不好玩。就像击中错误的音符不好玩，因为你击中一个错误的音符，每个人都能看出来。但在喜剧或像单口相声中，如果进展不顺利，你可以某种程度上，你知道，按摩它到你的……而且这在某种程度上取决于你，喜剧的伟大元素之一，当然，是惊喜的元素。但所以某种程度上，当你即将开始一个每个人都很熟悉的作品的新项目时，这些国家中的任何一个，你即将，你与每个人和你的团队进行的讨论是什么？你们进行的那些概念性对话是什么，会说，你知道，在这个特定的……当我们开始这个时，我们将要做这个。什么是……我们如何给他们惊喜？是的，正如我们在美国所说的，这上面的阻挡和铲球是什么？实际的X和O是什么？是的，你能走多远？嗯，这是一种悖论，因为当你走上舞台，比如说第一次排练，你知道，你一直在
great elements of comedy, certainly, is the element of surprise. But so sort of to that, when you're about to embark on a new project with a piece that everybody's very familiar with, any one of these countries, and you're about, what are the discussions that you have with everybody and with your team? What are the kind of conceptual conversations that you have that's going to say, you know, on this particular... When we embark on this, we're going to do this. What is the... How do we surprise them? Yeah, as we would say in America, what's the blocking and tackling on this? What is the actual X's and O's? Yeah, and how far can you go? Well, this is a kind of a paradox because when you go to the stage, let's say for the first rehearsal, you know, you have been
用乐谱准备你的诠释。你有总谱，你读，也许你听旧的录音。我有时尝试那样做，你知道，然后我停了一年，然后我回去检查我想……但当你到达时，这就是指挥的事情。当你到达舞台，管弦乐队演奏得完美，你做什么，你知道，你能说什么，你知道，这就是开始重新创造所有发生的事情的地方，你知道，用这种音乐。而且有一种联系，你知道，有一种……我不得不说加西亚·洛尔卡，西班牙诗人，他称之为Duende，你知道，有些人有，你知道，人们可以称之为魅力，天赋或所有这些，
preparing your interpretation with the score. You have the party tour, you read, maybe you listen to old recordings. I try to do that sometimes, you know, and then I stop for a year, and then I go back and I check the things that I want to... But then when you arrive, this is the thing of conducting. When you arrive to the stage and the orchestra played perfectly, what you do, you know, what you can say, you know, and there is the point where it starts the recreation of all of what has been happening, you know, with this music. And there is a connection, you know, there is a... I have to say García Lorca, the Spanish poet, he called Duende, leprecha, you know, that some people have, you know, people can call charisma, talent or all of that,
去连接，你知道，并以一种好的方式说服。对我来说，这是最重要的事情。当我解释某件事时，你需要有一个理由给他们。如果不是，就行不通，你知道，而且管弦乐队，他们能闻到血腥味，你知道，他们真的能知道你是否……这不是我必须……然后你必须导航，你知道，那个非常复杂的词。这就是为什么你需要有能力拥有你的诠释，确定你在做什么，但也灵活地在现场演奏音乐的时刻改变，你知道，在你演奏的时刻。而且看，我们在谈论贝多芬，你知道，你在音乐中有力度，你知道，强（forte），它必须强，弱（piano），
to connect, you know, and to convince in a good way. And for me, that is the most important thing. When I explain something, you need to have a reason for them. If not, doesn't work, you know, and the orchestras, they can smell the blood, you know, they can really know if you are... This is not really what I have to... And then you have to navigate, you know, that very complex word. That is why you need to have the ability to have your interpretation, to be sure what you are doing, but also be flexible to change in the moment that you are playing the music live, you know, in the moment that you are playing. And look, we were talking about Beethoven, you know, you in the music have the dynamics, you know, forte, it has to be strong, piano,
你必须柔和，中强（mezzo forte），你必须那样，你有快板（Allegro），你必须快，或柔板（Adagio），即使在贝多芬，你有节拍标记，例如，四分音符，80，他给了所有这些信息，但那是一个可以引导你诠释的信息，它不一定非得是，因为想象每个人都以完全相同的方式演奏。你认为那时他写下所有那些东西时，那是预期的吗？那是预期的所有表演者吗？我不这么认为，因为在这里在洛杉矶，我们做很多首演，我们做很多对新作曲家的委托，我们非常自豪，你知道。去年，我们委托了15部新作品，你知道，我们首演了所有这些。而且你看到作曲家的过程，作曲家，
you have to be soft, mezzo forte, you have to be like that, you have Allegro, you have to be fast, or Adagio, even in Beethoven, you have metronomic mark, for example, quarter note, 80, he gave all of that information, but that is an information that can guide you to interpret, it doesn't have to be, because imagine everybody playing in exactly the same way. And do you think that was expected back then when he wrote all of that stuff? Was it expected that all the performers? I don't think so, because for here in Los Angeles, we do a lot of premieres, we do a lot of commissions to new composers that we are very proud of, you know. This last year, we commissioned 15 new works, you know, and we premiere all of them. And you see the process of the composers, the composers,
他们甚至在第一次听音乐时，你看到他们修改音乐，他们改变东西，他们改变节奏。所以想象一下贝多芬在那个时候，你知道，它不是以同样的速度，你演奏一次协奏曲，五年后，它又被演奏了，而贝多芬已经死了，你知道，然后其他作曲家带来了，你知道，他们自己对贝多芬的诠释。所以再次，嗯，是那个作曲家死了，不是那只狗。我刚才看到威尔有点情绪化。因为在电影里，我不记得他死了。不，不，他没有。我没看续集，所以我不知道。古斯塔沃，你多少，因为显然没有广播，没有唱片，没有CD，没有办法听到这些音乐作品，除非它们
they even when they listen to the music the first time, you see they revise the music, they change things, they change tempo. So imagine Beethoven at that time, you know, it wasn't at the same speed, you play one concerto one time, five years later, it was played again, and Beethoven was already dead, you know, and then other composers were bringing, you know, their own interpretation of Beethoven. So again, well, it's that composer died, not the dog. I just saw him well getting a little emotional. Because in the movie, I don't remember him dying. No, no, no, he didn't. I didn't see the sequel, so I don't know. Gustavo, how much do you, since obviously there was no radio, no records, no CDs, there was no way to hear these pieces of music unless they
在过去被当面演奏。你认为贝多芬、海顿、莫扎特，其余的人是否假设这些音乐作品只有在他们指挥时才会被演奏。因此，他们的乐谱只是给他们自己的提醒，关于它要去哪里，如何指挥它，这就是我想变得更响的地方，这是我想变得更柔和、更快、更慢的时候，而不是像给未来的人的声明或规则。是的。有关于那个的任何写作吗？你和任何学者谈过那个吗？是的，很多，你知道，例如，对于莫扎特，对于贝多芬，甚至对于巴赫，你知道，他是一位伟大的指挥家。他已经去世了，尼古拉斯·哈农库特。他是一位奥地利指挥家，
were played in front of you back in the day. Do you think that the assumption was made by Beethoven, Haydn Mozart, the rest of that these pieces of music would only get played when they conducted them. And therefore, their sheet music was just a reminder for themselves about where it's going, how to conduct it, which is where I want to get louder, this is when I want to get softer, faster, slower, and less like a less a declaration or rules for people going forward in the future. Yeah. Is there any writing about that? Have you talked to any scholars about that? Yes, a lot, you know, for example, for Mozart, for Beethoven, even for Bach, you know, he's a great conductor. He already died, Nicolas Harnorcourt. He was an Austrian conductor,
他是这种音乐的专家，尽管他对所有诠释都非常开放。但大多数这些作曲家，他们是伟大的音乐会钢琴家，你知道，贝多芬，莫扎特，他们演奏他们所有的协奏曲，他们指挥，指挥的形象或指挥的工作在那个时候不存在。哦，真的吗？他们指挥他们自己的作品。他们演奏他们自己的作品。他们演奏。你知道，在中间，我想门德尔松是第一批主要指挥家之一，你知道，费利克斯·门德尔松，他是个神童，他在诠释贝多芬，并且他以某种方式重新发现了巴赫，例如。而且是的，但如果你看，你知道，有很多信息要遵循。而且在风格上，你可以看到，
and he was a specialist in this music, even though he was very open to all interpretations. But most of these composers, they were great concert pianists, you know, Beethoven, Mozart, they play all of their concertos, they conducted the image of the conductor or the work of a conductor didn't exist at that time. Oh, really? They were conducting their own pieces. They were playing their own pieces. They were playing. You know, in the middle, I think Mendelssohn was one of the first main conductors, you know, Felix Mendelssohn, that he was a prodigy, and he was interpreting Beethoven, and he rediscovered in a way Bach, for example. And yes, but if you see, you know, there is a lot of information to follow. And also stylistically, you can see,
你可以跟随，你知道，有时你不能用1000名音乐家演奏莫扎特交响曲，但你可以演奏贝多芬交响曲，第九交响曲，有1000人在合唱团里，还有一个大管弦乐队，你知道，而且它们非常接近。我认为他们所有人都遵循一种风格。例如，海顿是贝多芬的老师，也是莫扎特的老师，然后其他人跟随那个，他们正在发展，你知道，一种风格。我认为那是诠释的发展。但如果你听，有很多20世纪初的录音，管弦乐队听起来和我们现在听到的管弦乐队完全不同。但演奏的方式，演奏的方式是完全的，是非常自由的。那里什么都没有。
you can follow, you know, sometimes you cannot play a Mozart symphony with 1000 musicians, but you can play a Beethoven symphony, the ninth with 1000 people in the choir and with a big orchestra, you know, and they are so close. I think all of them, they follow a style. For example, Haydn was master of Beethoven, also of Mozart, and then the others were following that, and they were developing, you know, a style. I think that is the develop of the interpretation. But if you listen to, there are a lot of recordings from the beginning of the 20th century, the orchestra sounded really different to how we listen to the orchestras now completely. But also the way to play, the way to play was completely, was very free. It was nothing there.
而且我喜欢那个。那是我的，有时是我诠释事情的方式。那是，你认为它是，几乎像是一种过度教学和过度感觉一切都必须完美的功能吗，就像每个人都有，现在有这么多不同的资源，人们可以永远学习，而那时它更自然，而不是机械化。你注意到了吗？你可能不想那样说，但是……不，但我们处于一个很难在有时一个管弦乐队和另一个管弦乐队之间做出区别的地方，因为他们演奏得非常相似。让我们说水平现在非常高，而在其他时候，管弦乐队就像一个俱乐部。一些音乐家聚在一起演奏，
And I love that. That is my, sometimes my way to interpret things. Is that because do you think it's a function of, there's almost like an overteaching and over a sense that everything has to be perfect, like everybody has, there's so many different resources now, and people can study forever and back then it was much more organic, as opposed to robotic. Do you notice? You probably don't want to say that, but... No, but we are in a place where it's very difficult to make a difference between sometimes one orchestra and another, because they play very similar. Let's say the level is very high right now, where in other times the orchestras were like a club. Some musicians going to play together,
像舒伯特，你知道，舒伯特沙龙（Schubertiadas）。他找了一些音乐家来演奏他的音乐等等。那是为了好玩。然后他变得，你知道，稍微更专业一点等等。但我认为这就是我们艺术现在的重点。完美是我们试图找到的吗？但什么完美？因为如果完美不存在，你知道，它不存在，你知道？而且我喜欢那个完美错误的那个空间，你知道？我将其视为我们所做真实行动的美丽。所以古斯塔沃，有时我变得非常过度浪漫，关于当我听古典音乐时，我正在穿越回过去的概念。嗯，那是他们那个时代的流行歌星，对吧？是的。是的。莫扎特是那个人，你知道。
like Schubert, you know, the Schubertiadas. He got some musicians to play his music and all of that. It was for fun. Then he got, you know, a little bit more professional and all of that. But I think that that is the point of our art right now. Is perfection where we are trying to find? But what perfection? Because if perfection doesn't exist, you know, it doesn't exist, you know? And I love that space of the perfect mistake, you know? I perceive that as a beauty of the real action of what we do. So Gustavo, sometimes I get really overly sort of romantic about the notion that when I listen to a piece of classical music, I am traveling back in time. Well, those were the pop stars of their time, right? Yeah. Yes. Mozart was the guy, you know.
那是碧昂丝和……正是。瑞克·艾斯利和任何什么。一切。所以莫扎特是什么时候搬到丛林的？因为我……不，威尔，再说一次，那是电视节目。我不能准确地向你解释那个，因为那件事是受我的历史启发，你知道？《丛林中的莫扎特》。顺便说一句，我确实听说了。所以那是真的，对吧？是的，酷。但你没参加那个或者你没在那个里指挥什么吗？我是舞台经理。哦，哇。盖尔来了，你知道，罗德里戈，那个角色，作为客座指挥来到洛杉矶，
Those were the Beyoncé's and... Exactly. Rick Astley's and whatever. Everything. So when was it that Mozart moved to the jungle? Because I... No, Will, again, that's a TV show. I can't explain you exactly that, because that thing was inspired by my history, you know? Mozart in the jungle. By the way, I did hear that. So that's true, right? Yes, cool. But weren't you on that or didn't you conduct something in that? I was a stage manager. Oh, wow. Gael came, you know, Rodrigo, that is the character, came to Los Angeles as a guest conductor,
然后我是舞台经理。所以我帮他，你知道，上台，我告诉他每个人都讨厌洛杉矶爱乐乐团的指挥。古斯塔沃，我想问你，因为这么多人认为古典音乐家和指挥家以及我们所有人都是彻头彻尾的书呆子，我们某种程度上确实是。我曾经是，现在仍然是。但他们认为这就是我们整天做的事情。所以你有没有，比如……每当你完成一场音乐会，你的肾上腺素在飙升，你感觉很好，你有没有想过回家喝得烂醉并播放说唱音乐？并玩《龙与地下城》？我喜欢所有的音乐。
and then I was the stage manager. So I helped him, you know, to get to the stage and I told him that everybody hate the conductor of the Los Angeles Philharmonic. Gustavo, I want to ask you, because so many people think that classical musicians and conductors and all of us are total nerds, which we kind of are. I was and I still am. But they think that's all we do all day long. So do you ever like... Whenever you're done with a concert and your adrenaline is pumping and you're feeling great, do you ever just come home and get wasted and play rap music? And play Dungeons and Dragons? I love all music.
你喜欢吗？有什么你不喜欢的吗？不，不，不，不。你知道，也许有些音乐我不喜欢一直听，但这并不意味着我不喜欢那种音乐，你知道？因为我非常开放。我来自……我的父亲是长号手，他在一个拉丁乐队演奏。他有一个萨尔萨乐队。所以我曾经想成为一名萨尔萨演奏家。你知道，我想成为像纽约的La Fania等等，但我成为了一名古典音乐家。你演奏的乐器是什么？小提琴？小提琴。那是你最喜欢的乐器还是只是你演奏得最好的那个？不，你知道，对我来说成为一名指挥……你必须知道如何演奏所有这些吗？
You do? Is there anything that you don't like? No, no, no, no. You know, maybe there is music that I don't like to listen all the time, but that doesn't mean that I don't like that music, you know? Because I'm very open. I'm coming from... My father is a trombone player and he played in a Latin band. He has a salsa band. So I wanted to be a salsa player. You know, I wanted to be like La Fania in New York and all of that, but I became a classical musician. What is your instrument that you play? Violin? Violin. Is that your favorite instrument or just the one you play best? No, you know, for me to be a conductor... You have to know how to play all of them?
不是演奏，而是了解乐器，你知道？但我喜欢长号，因为我认为它是激励我成为音乐家的乐器。我喜欢小提琴，因为它是我的主要乐器，但我喜欢钢琴，例如，我演奏一点，而且我喜欢所有的乐器。但昨天，例如，我正在阅读，我放了一些平克·弗洛伊德。你知道，我喜欢平克·弗洛伊德。那是《月之暗面》。我昨天在听，然后我停下来，然后我正在，你知道，研究勋伯格的《古雷之歌》，例如，或者我拿一些我喜欢的说唱音乐。对我来说，音乐没有任何边界。这是一个现实。我不喜欢，你知道，把这种音乐放在这里或这种音乐不好，你知道？
Not to play, but to know about the instruments, you know? But I love the trombone because I think it was the instrument that inspired me to be a musician. I love the violin because it's my main instrument, but I love the piano, for example, that I play a little bit, and I love all instruments in general. But yesterday, for example, I was reading and I put some Pink Floyd. You know, I love Pink Floyd. It was the dark side of the moon. I was listening yesterday and then I stopped and then I was, you know, studying Guru leader by Schoenberg, for example, or I take some rap music that I love. For me, music doesn't have any kind of border. That is a reality. I don't like, you know, to put this music here or this music is not good, you know?
所以这里有一个我问你们所有人的问题。我想我从肖恩开始，然后我去找杰森，然后古斯塔沃，你最后。你最喜欢的古典音乐作品或作曲家或任何什么是什么？你的首选是什么？哪一个是总是你回到那个的东西，那是你喜欢的真正激励你的作品？你知道，这很有趣。我本来要问古斯塔沃，因为我，我是在这位钢琴老师身边长大的，她非常不可思议，她的丈夫是一位在芝加哥地区指挥的指挥家，哈罗德·鲍尔，如果你在听，哈罗德。他非常不可思议，他是我的大导师，他，我问他，我，我一定才10岁。我当时想，哈罗德，如果你只能听，
So here's a question I have for all of you. And I guess I'll start with Sean, then I'll go to Jason and then Gustavo, you go last. What is your favorite piece or composer or whatever of classical music? What's your go-to? What's the one that has always been the thing you go back to is that's the piece that I love that really inspires you? You know, it's funny. I was going to ask Gustavo because I had, I grew up with this piano teacher who was incredible and her husband who was a conductor in the Chicagoland area, Harold Bauer, if you're listening, Harold. And he was incredible and he was a big mentor to me and he, I asked him, I was, I must have been like 10 years old. I was like, Harold, if you could only listen to,
如果你只能听一位作曲家余生，他就像，哦，那是不可能的。我说，我知道，但你必须选。所以我选莫扎特。我想他说，我想他说舒伯特或舒曼，一些意想不到的。但我的会是莫扎特。我的意思是，当然，他可能是最受欢迎的，你知道，他是17世纪的流行音乐。是的，绝对。你知道，但那是我的长答案。杰森。我很尴尬地说，我仍然没有完成只是用贝多芬和莫扎特填满自己。我一直在，我实际上越来越喜欢海顿，因为我听说他激励了贝多芬。所以我当时想，好吧。所以，而且我有，我注意到了那里的相似之处，就其范围，其大小而言，
if you only could listen to one composer for the rest of your life, he's like, oh, that's impossible. I go, I know, but you have to pick. So I would pick Mozart. I think he said, I think he said Schubert or Schumann, something unexpected. But mine would be Mozart. I mean, sure, he's probably the most popular, you know, he is the pop music of the 17th century. Yeah, absolutely. You know, but that's my long answer. Jason. I am embarrassed to say that I still have not finished just filling myself with Beethoven and Mozart. I've been, I've actually gotten more and more into Haydn because I heard that he inspired Beethoven. So I was like, okay. So, and I have, I have noticed the similarities there as far as the, how the scope of it, the size of it,
他写的宏伟。而且还有柴可夫斯基。我也发现了。而且加上我是《胡桃夹子组曲》的忠实粉丝。所以，你知道，我喜欢那个。但柴可夫斯基的第五交响曲是我真正，我真正感到兴奋的东西。还有这些有趣的，某种程度上勇敢的部分，变得非常安静。而且我喜欢柴可夫斯基。顺便说一句，同性恋家伙。但最终，贝多芬。我会说贝多芬的钢琴协奏曲，特别是第四和第五。所以，所以等等，古斯塔沃，我让你说完。我会说我的。而且我知道，我知道的比你们少得多。但我的，我通常做的事情，当涉及到这个时，只有当涉及到这个时，我喜欢拉赫玛尼诺夫，钢琴协奏曲。那些，那些对我说话
the majesty of, of what he, what he wrote. And also, Tchaikovsky too. I've found as well. And plus I'm a big fan of the Nutcracker Suite. And so, you know, I love that. But Tchaikovsky's fifth symphony is something I've really, I've really gotten excited about it. There's these fun sort of plucky parts too that get down really quiet. And I love Tchaikovsky. Gay guy, by the way. But ultimately, Beethoven. I would say the Beethoven's piano concertos, and the specifically four and five. So, so wait, Gustavo, I'll let you finish. I will say mine. And I know, I know so much less than all of you. But my, the thing that I do generally, when it comes to this, only when it comes to this, I love Rachmaninoff, the piano concertos. Those, those speak to me
他作品的宏伟壮丽。还有柴可夫斯基，我也很喜欢。另外，我是《胡桃夹子组曲》的忠实粉丝，所以我很喜欢它。但柴可夫斯基的第五交响曲让我感到非常兴奋。其中有一些很有趣、轻快的部分，声音会变得非常安静。我非常喜欢柴可夫斯基。顺便说一下，他是一位同性恋者。但归根结底，还是贝多芬。我会说是贝多芬的钢琴协奏曲，特别是第四和第五部。等等，古斯塔沃，我让你说完。我会说出我的选择。我知道我比你们所有人都了解得少得多。但就这件事而言，通常情况下，只有在这件事上，我喜欢拉赫玛尼诺夫的钢琴协奏曲。那些作品能引起我的共鸣。
in a way they're so. The second one is famously the most, like the most difficult piano playing out there, isn't there? Yeah. Just dark. And also, do you know the song all by myself, all by myself, right? That's based on a Rachmaninoff concerto. Oh, really? All by myself is. Yes, I knew that. Also, also based on it is, do you know that, that commercial goes, the best part of waking up is full. Gustavo, I have to apologize. That's also based on Rachmaninoff. Wow, that's a girl. Yeah, if you think about the best part of waking up. Yeah, I got it. So that's, that's mine. I know very little, but it is something that always just speaks to me. Rachmaninoff always gets me. I don't know why. It, who knows why things affect us the way they do. What about you?
某种程度上它们就是这样。第二首钢琴曲是公认的最难演奏的曲目之一，不是吗？是的。简直太深奥了。还有，你知道《All by myself》这首歌吗？就是《All by myself》，对吧？那是基于拉赫玛尼诺夫的协奏曲改编的。哦，真的吗？《All by myself》是吗？是的，我知道。还有，你知道那个广告吗？“唤醒一天的最佳方式是……”，古斯塔沃，我得道歉。那也是基于拉赫玛尼诺夫的作品。哇，那真是太棒了。是的，如果你想想“唤醒一天的最佳方式”。是的，我明白了。所以这就是我的了解。我知道的很少，但它总是能触动我。拉赫玛尼诺夫总是能打动我。我不知道为什么。谁知道为什么事物会以这种方式影响我们呢？你呢？
No, but you are right, you know, you are all of you in talking about the greatest composers, you know, Rachmaninoff is an amazing, post-romantic composer and is full of passion. That is what is Rachmaninoff about passion, virtuosity, you know, full of feelings, you know, even hiding is the maestro, the master, you know, the music, I believe. And Mozart, you know, even, you know, if you listen to the, the name of Mozart is also, you know, I think one of my favorite composers. It's difficult, again, to say one composer for me. Very difficult. Because I will say, you know, for example, I love Jonathan's music like crazy. And I have the chance to premiere a lot of his pieces. And he's a contemporary composer. Who is this? The Jonas Brothers? John Adams. Oh, John. The Jonas Brothers
不，你是对的，你知道，你们在谈论最伟大的作曲家时，拉赫玛尼诺夫是一位了不起的后浪漫主义作曲家，充满了激情。这就是拉赫玛尼诺夫的精髓：激情、精湛的技艺，充满了情感，甚至隐藏着大师的风范。莫扎特也是，你知道，如果你听听莫扎特的名字，我认为他也是我最喜欢的作曲家之一。对我来说，很难只说出一位作曲家。非常难。因为我会说，例如，我疯狂地热爱约翰·亚当斯的音乐。我有机会首演了他的许多作品。他是一位当代作曲家。他是谁？乔纳斯兄弟吗？约翰·亚当斯。哦，约翰。乔纳斯兄弟。
that I like. But John Adams, he's a Californian composer. And he's great. He wrote an amazing opera, Nixon in China. And he has, you know, a lot of wonderful pieces for the Philharmonic. But I will say, oof, difficult, but Beethoven. Anything from him, yeah? Because he has that crossover from the classical period to the romantic period, right? So he kind of covers a little bit about exactly, but especially if you know, I have conduct all the symphonies, I have conduct all the piano concertos. I have studied his opera, his only opera, Fidelio. But I will say, you know, when he was at the end of his life, he was writing chamber music. He stopped to write in symphonic music. And for me, that is the most complete music, maybe that
我喜欢的。但约翰·亚当斯，他是一位加州作曲家。他很棒。他写了一部了不起的歌剧《尼克松在中国》。他为爱乐乐团创作了许多美妙的作品。但我会说，呼，很难，但贝多芬。他的任何作品，对吧？因为他完成了从古典主义时期到浪漫主义时期的跨越，对吧？所以他涵盖了一点点，但特别是如果你知道的话，我指挥过他所有的交响曲，我指挥过他所有的钢琴协奏曲。我研究过他的歌剧，他唯一的歌剧《费德里奥》。但我会说，你知道，在他生命的最后阶段，他在创作室内乐。他停止了交响乐的创作。对我来说，那可能是最完整的音乐。
exists. You know, when you go to the late quartets of Beethoven, when you go to the great fugue, for example, that he wrote, that is music that still, you know, in the modernity, I think it's not any composer that have achieved that kind of, you know, level of intellectual, spiritual, all of these things together, all of these human things together and superhuman things together in such a small dimension for musicians. The string quartets? The late string quartets. How come he only did one violin concerto? And one opera. I love that. Only one. And look, it was, I think he did also an arrangement for piano for that concerto, because he's such a beautiful concerto. But I think it's because
存在的。你知道，当你去听贝多芬的晚期四重奏，当你去听他创作的《大赋格》时，那是即使在现代，我认为也没有任何作曲家能达到那种智力、精神层面，所有这些东西结合在一起，所有这些人类的东西和超人的东西结合在一起，对于音乐家来说，在如此小的维度里。弦乐四重奏？晚期弦乐四重奏。他怎么只写了一首小提琴协奏曲？还有一部歌剧。我喜欢这一点。只有一部。你看，我想他也为那首协奏曲做了钢琴改编版，因为它是一首如此优美的协奏曲。但我认为这是因为
he was a piano player, you know, and he was very close to one of these great violins, I forget the name, that he wrote the violin concerto, but he wrote also sonatas for violin and piano. That is also that he wrote the spring, all of that. The piano sonatas also. Did we just find our project together? Which one? A violin piano, a violin piano. Well, we do, of course, but I have to go back to the violin, my God, because that is difficult. I have years that I don't play. Well, both screwed up together. And what did you say? The perfect mistake? Yeah, exactly. Beethoven did not, he only did five of those piano concertos. He did nine
他是一位钢琴演奏家，你知道，他与当时的一位伟大小提琴家关系非常密切，我忘了名字，他为他写了小提琴协奏曲，但他还写了小提琴和钢琴奏鸣曲。这也是他写的《春天》，所有这些。还有钢琴奏鸣曲。我们刚刚找到了我们的合作项目了吗？哪一个？小提琴钢琴，小提琴钢琴。嗯，我们当然可以，但我得回到小提琴上，天哪，因为那太难了。我已经好几年没拉了。嗯，两个一起搞砸了。你说什么？完美的错误？是的，完全正确。贝多芬没有，他只写了五首钢琴协奏曲。他写了九首
symphonies. And then you look at what Mozart did, what Haydn did. He was not, dare I say, that prolific? Or am I, is that a huge mistake to say? I think his process was completely different. He was a genius in a kind of way. He didn't want to produce a lot of things. He wanted to, when you see the sketches, he's writing a lot of ideas, a lot of ideas. And to arrive to the piece that he wrote, it took a long time. Mozart was writing music like, you know, like a computer. You know, he wrote violin concertos because he played the concertos. He wrote the piano concertos because he played. He loved the clarinet. He wrote the first clarinet concerto. That's my favorite. It's amazing. And this is maybe the most beautiful
交响曲。然后你看看莫扎特做了什么，海顿做了什么。他不是，我敢说，那么高产吗？或者我，那样说是一个巨大的错误吗？我认为他的创作过程完全不同。他在某种程度上是个天才。他不想大量生产东西。他想要，当你看到草稿时，他写了很多想法，很多想法。为了达到他最终写出的作品，他花了很多时间。莫扎特写音乐就像，你知道，像一台电脑。你知道，他写小提琴协奏曲是因为他演奏这些协奏曲。他写钢琴协奏曲是因为他演奏。他热爱单簧管。他写了第一首单簧管协奏曲。那是我的最爱。太棒了。这可能是最美丽的
clarinet concerto that exists. It was written by Mozart. But yes, I think Beethoven was in a more, he was in another dimension in the sense of writing the music and the reason. He was also an star in his time. He was a superstar, you know, and everybody was like crazy about him. But he was more, you know, maybe because he was not listening also. He got to that intimate world. Where do you weigh in on Wagner? He seems like a very complex character. Well, I have been studying Wagner these days, you know. And the thing with Wagner is the language also, you know, sometimes to listen to an opera for six hours in German, that is not a language that maybe you are not close. It can be kind of heavy. But I have to say that Wagner is one of the
单簧管协奏曲。它是莫扎特写的。但是的，我认为贝多芬处于一个更，他在创作音乐和原因方面处于另一个维度。他在当时也是一位明星。他是一位超级巨星，你知道，每个人都为他疯狂。但他更，你知道，也许因为他听不见，他也进入了那个私密的世界。你对瓦格纳怎么看？他看起来是一个非常复杂的人物。嗯，我最近一直在研究瓦格纳，你知道。瓦格纳的问题也在于语言，你知道，有时听六个小时的德语歌剧，那可能不是你熟悉的语言。可能会觉得有点沉重。但我必须说，瓦格纳是
most creative and unique composers that exist, you know. He's the heart of the post-romanticism. He's the heart of Mala, of the beginning of the Dodecafonism, Brugner. He was a very influential composer, right? And so many young composers came. By the will for everything. He was vegetarian. All the artists were vegetarian. Oh, Maestro Wagner was, he go back to eat meat. Everybody was following that. He was like, he was a god. He was a god for the people. And he wrote these beautiful operas that I love. Of course, I get more close sometimes to Italian because I speak Spanish. So it's in his Latin language, you know, and it makes more sense for me. But when I'm studying, for example, Rangel, or I'm studying Law and Green, or the Götterdammerung, or Tan
最富有创造力和独特的作曲家之一，你知道。他是后浪漫主义的核心。他是马勒的核心，是十二音体系的开端，布鲁克纳。他是一位非常有影响力的作曲家，对吧？许多年轻的作曲家都来了。为了他的一切。他是素食主义者。所有的艺术家都是素食主义者。哦，瓦格纳大师是，他回去吃肉了。每个人都跟着做。他就像，他是一位神。他对于人们来说是一位神。他写了这些我热爱的美妙歌剧。当然，我有时更接近意大利歌剧，因为我说西班牙语。所以它是拉丁语系，你知道，对我来说更有意义。但当我研究时，例如《莱茵的黄金》，或者我研究《罗恩格林》，或者《诸神的黄昏》，或者《唐
Heuser, it's also such a beautiful music. And I try to study the text to understand why that music is written. But I love Wagner. So cool. There are as many composers today that there were back in those days. And we just don't hear as much about them because they aren't the rock stars of today as they were back then. Or has composing orchestral music become something that is not that widely done nowadays? There are some composers that are not play a lot, and they are really good. I have done some of them, especially, you know, beginning of the 20th century composers. And for example, there is an amazing composer, the father of the American music, we can say, that is Charles Ives, for example. And one of my last projects with the Philharmonic
豪瑟》，那也是如此美妙的音乐。我试着研究歌词来理解为什么写那段音乐。但我爱瓦格纳。太酷了。今天有像过去那样多的作曲家吗？我们只是没有听到那么多关于他们的消息，因为他们不是像当时那样的摇滚明星。还是说创作管弦乐已经成为一种现在不太普遍的事情了？有一些作曲家没有被演奏很多，但他们真的很好。我演奏过他们中的一些，特别是，你知道，20世纪初的作曲家。例如，有一位了不起的作曲家，我们可以说是美国音乐之父，那就是查尔斯·艾夫斯。我和爱乐乐团的最后一个项目之一
before the quarantine was to play, we play all his symphonies, his fourth symphonies, you know. And he's really the voice of the American music, you know, because it didn't exist in American music. It was European. The influence in classical music was very European. All of the maestros came from Europe. They studied with Brahms and with the main composers and teachers in Europe. And the education was very European. And then it came this guy, you know, writing folk songs, music that he was listening from the military bands marching. So he created a world. Listen to Charles Ives because that is a composer that is unique. And I love to do his music. While you're recommending composers, I want to ask you this before you go.
在隔离之前是演奏，我们演奏了他所有的交响曲，他的第四交响曲，你知道。他确实是美国音乐的声音，你知道，因为当时不存在美国音乐。它是欧洲的。古典音乐的影响非常欧洲化。所有的指挥家都来自欧洲。他们和勃拉姆斯以及欧洲的主要作曲家和老师一起学习。教育非常欧洲化。然后这个家伙出现了，你知道，写民歌，他从行进的军乐队中听到的音乐。所以他创造了一个世界。听听查尔斯·艾夫斯，因为那是一位独特的作曲家。我喜欢演奏他的音乐。在你推荐作曲家的时候，在你走之前我想问你这个。
If I wanted to continue to broaden away from Beethoven, Mozart, through Haydn, Tchaikovsky, who, if that is descriptive of what my taste is, who would you recommend I listen to? Lou, you have to go to Schumann. You know, Robert Schumann, you know, it's like, oof. A minor piano concerto is great. Exactly. And he is the romantic of all romantics for me, you know. And did he precede those or follow them? Yes, he received all of that influence. Berlioz is an amazing composer, also a French composer. He is symphony fantastic, he's amazing, but also he's Faust, dimension of Faust. He's an amazing music opera. Mendelssohn is an amazing composer too. Let me tell you, Brahms. I mean, you mentioned Ives, who obviously was so good as
如果我想继续从贝多芬、莫扎特、海顿、柴可夫斯基中拓宽视野，如果这能描述我的品味，你会推荐我听谁的？卢，你必须去听舒曼。你知道，罗伯特·舒曼，你知道，就像，呼。A小调钢琴协奏曲很棒。完全正确。对我来说，他是浪漫主义者中的浪漫主义者，你知道。他是先于他们还是追随他们？是的，他接受了所有这些影响。柏辽兹是一位了不起的作曲家，也是一位法国作曲家。他的《幻想交响曲》很棒，但他的《浮士德的沉沦》也是一部了不起的歌剧音乐。门德尔松也是一位了不起的作曲家。让我告诉你，勃拉姆斯。我的意思是，你提到了艾夫斯，他显然是
the voice of the snowman and that Rudolph the Red Nose reindeer. Oh, no, Will, you missed it again. That's Burl Ives. That's Burl Ives. Got it. Got it. That's Burl Ives. Gustavo, how have you enjoyed, if you have, conducting at the ball when they put the movie up on the screen, and then you play the music from the movie, which I think is an incredible program that you guys do. I think I saw what I say, I saw 2001 there, I saw E.T. there. It's just amazing. They pull everything out, Will, except just the music, and then the music is live. It's a very sad, it's a very sad time because for the first time in 99 years, we will not have the season of the Hollywood Bowl. And the other day it went and it was empty. But at the same time,
雪人和鲁道夫红鼻子驯鹿的声音。哦，不，威尔，你又搞错了。那是伯尔·艾夫斯。那是伯尔·艾夫斯。明白了。明白了。那是伯尔·艾夫斯。古斯塔沃，当他们在屏幕上放电影，然后你们演奏电影里的音乐时，你喜欢在好莱坞露天剧场指挥吗？我认为这是一个你们做的不可思议的项目。我想我看到了，我说，我在那里看了《2001太空漫游》，我在那里看了《E.T.》。这真是太棒了。他们把一切都去掉了，威尔，只剩下音乐，然后音乐是现场演奏的。这是一个非常悲伤的时刻，因为99年来第一次，我们将没有好莱坞露天剧场的演出季。前几天我去看了，它是空的。但与此同时，
as we were talking at the beginning, every crisis brings opportunities and we are rethinking what to do, how to do things. But really, I became a fan of the Hollywood Bowl more than conducting, going to listen to concerts, having the chance to listen to music, to share with my family at dinner and drink something and be with my friends. What's your favorite concert that you've seen there at the top of your head, I'm sure? Well, no. Look, I went to Pet Sounds, for example, with Brian Wilson, and I was dating my wife, and that was one of the best dates in my life. I went to a concert of Sting in Peter Gabriel, that was unbelievable, amazing. But also, but also, you know, thousands of concerts, I have done concerts with Latin artists like Juan Luis
正如我们开头所谈到的，每一次危机都带来机遇，我们正在重新思考做什么，如何做事。但真的，我成为了好莱坞露天剧场的粉丝，不仅仅是去指挥，而是去听音乐会，有机会听音乐，和家人共进晚餐，喝点东西，和朋友在一起。你脑海中在那儿看过的最喜欢的音乐会是什么？嗯，不。看，我去听了《Pet Sounds》，例如，和布莱恩·威尔逊一起，当时我在和我妻子约会，那是我一生中最好的约会之一。我去听了斯汀和彼得·盖布瑞尔的音乐会，那真是令人难以置信，太棒了。但还有，你知道，成千上万场音乐会，我和拉丁艺术家一起做过音乐会，比如胡安·路易斯
Herra, and with Natalia Lafruca, with Café Tacuba, and also the great classics, you know. I went to listen to a friend, you know, conducting Borges, symphonies, Gio Giooma playing all the cello suites, only him, you know, on the stage of the Hollywood Bowl, one cello player, 18,000 people, that was amazing. So, thousands of things, I love the Hollywood Bowl a lot. I played there last year with the Lebec sisters, you know, the two pianists. Yes, great friends. Yeah, the carnival of the animals. Speaking of empty Hollywood Bowl, right? Yeah. That's weird. Will, you cut out for a second. So, Gustavo, I wanted to talk about YOLA, because YOLA, which is the youth orchestra, Los Angeles, right, that you started, because it seems like the first thing that gets cut out of the federal
格拉，还有娜塔莉亚·拉福卡德，卡菲·塔库巴，还有伟大的古典音乐，你知道。我去听了一位朋友，你知道，指挥博尔赫斯，交响曲，乔·乔玛演奏所有的巴赫大提琴组曲，只有他一个人，你知道，在好莱坞露天剧场的舞台上，一位大提琴手，18000人，那真是太棒了。所以，成千上万的事情，我非常喜欢好莱坞露天剧场。去年我和勒贝克姐妹，你知道，那两位钢琴家在那里演奏。是的，好朋友。是的，动物狂欢节。说到空荡荡的好莱坞露天剧场，对吧？是的。那很奇怪。威尔，你刚才断线了。所以，古斯塔沃，我想谈谈YOLA，因为YOLA，也就是洛杉矶青年管弦乐团，对吧，你创办的，因为看起来最先被从联邦
budget or even local budgets is the arts. At the same time, you know, we'll toss an extra trillion dollars to the armed forces when every man, woman, and child loves movies, television, theater, music, you know. So, talk about that a little bit and why it's so important to you, because I think it's, I don't understand why we're constantly picking up the slack for the government to fund arts ourselves and to expose children to it. This is a very important topic, you know. It's a very important discussion that, as an artistic institution, we have to talk, you know, because it's about education also. Right. And I think, and it's about identity, it's culture, you know. It's not an entertainment thing. It's not a luxurious thing, you know. Right.
预算甚至地方预算中削减的就是艺术。与此同时，你知道，我们会给武装部队多扔一万亿美元，而每个男人、女人和孩子都热爱电影、电视、戏剧、音乐，你知道。所以，谈谈这个，为什么它对你如此重要，因为我认为，我不明白为什么我们总是要为政府填补资金缺口来资助艺术，并让孩子们接触它。这是一个非常重要的话题，你知道。这是一个非常重要的讨论，作为艺术机构，我们必须谈论，你知道，因为它也关乎教育。对。我认为，它关乎身份，它是文化，你知道。它不是一种娱乐，它不是一种奢侈品，你知道。对。
As you can see, art, art has to be, culture has to be a right for everybody and it has to be an essential part of the education of our new generations. Yeah. Contemplation, you know, creating beauty together, creating harmony together. Well, and also, you know, as a kid, like I started at five years old, like I said, and I didn't even realize at such a young age that it teaches structure and goal setting and discipline, you know. And discipline, yeah. And how do you listen to each other? And by the way, and spirituality on a certain level, too. Absolutely. And I'm not talking about religion. I'm talking about actual, you know, all those things that are so vital to society. Yeah. But imagine that process. I can put the
如你所见，艺术，艺术必须是，文化必须是每个人的权利，它必须是我们新一代教育的重要组成部分。是的。沉思，你知道，一起创造美，一起创造和谐。嗯，还有，你知道，作为一个孩子，就像我五岁开始一样，就像我说的，我甚至没有意识到在那么小的年纪，它教会了结构、目标设定和纪律，你知道。还有纪律，是的。以及你如何倾听彼此？顺便说一句，在某种程度上也有灵性。绝对的。我说的不是宗教。我指的是实际的，你知道，所有那些对社会至关重要的东西。是的。但想象一下那个过程。我可以举
example of a child, you know, in his house, playing a violin. He's creating his own world that he will share with other people in an orchestra for other people because it's the action, you know, of what we create that goes to the audience and the audience received and we have. So Yola started because I'm coming from a program, an artistic social program in my country called called a system that music is being used as a tool for social change. And it has been very successful since 1975 that my maestro created. We have achieved more than a million of children having access to music as part of their education. And that was the first thing that I committed. I said, you know, I will go to Los Angeles. I will accept this amazing honor if we create
一个孩子的例子，你知道，在他家里，拉小提琴。他正在创造他自己的世界，他将在管弦乐团中与其他人为其他人分享，因为这是行动，你知道，我们创造的东西传达给观众，观众接收到，我们拥有。所以YOLA的创办是因为我来自我国家的一个艺术社会项目，叫做“El Sistema”，音乐被用作社会变革的工具。自1975年我的大师创立以来，它非常成功。我们已经实现了超过一百万的孩子有机会将音乐作为他们教育的一部分。这是我承诺的第一件事。我说，你知道，我会去洛杉矶。如果我们要创造
something that goes to the heart of the community. And this was the thing to create a youth orchestra that it's not only for playing or for it was an orchestra to help to these children to have a voice because we went to the communities with difficulties. And we are we are talking about that, you know, I think as Mother Teresa de Calcutta said, the worst thing to be poor is to be no one is about to be excluded. And that is the thing with poverty, you know, that is the thing with the unbalance of our societies. Then when you give the possibility to a kid to have art as part of their life, you know, you are giving something that is a treasure because you have all of these elements, you know, you have spirituality, you have discipline, you are creating beauty for others
一些深入社区核心的东西，我会接受这个了不起的荣誉。这就是创办一个青年管弦乐团的事情，它不仅仅是为了演奏，它是一个帮助这些孩子拥有声音的管弦乐团，因为我们去了有困难的社区。我们正在谈论这个，你知道，我认为正如加尔各答的特蕾莎修女所说，贫穷最糟糕的事情是成为“无名氏”，是被排斥。这就是贫穷的问题，你知道，这就是我们社会不平衡的问题。当你给孩子一个机会，让他们把艺术作为生活的一部分时，你知道，你给予的是一种宝藏，因为你拥有所有这些元素，你知道，你有灵性，你有纪律，你正在为他人创造美
and you are creating beauty for yourself and for your and for the people. You can see kids light up whenever there's a music programmer, any kind of art. We need to give the chance to our children to have beauty in their life, in the real sense of beauty, you know, to have the chance for them to contemplate, to create. And this is the thing with Yola and it has to be the thing with our artistic institution. Our artistic institution have to reflect what is the community, you know, and sometimes we don't see that and people don't feel identified with that and that is why they don't have access or they don't want to go to that because classical music is elitist, I don't have the chance to go there. But then when you bring the classical music, for example, to the
你正在为你自己和人们创造美。每当有音乐节目或任何形式的艺术时，你可以看到孩子们眼睛发亮。我们需要给我们的孩子机会，让他们的生活中拥有美，真正意义上的美，你知道，让他们有机会沉思、创造。这就是YOLA的事情，它也必须是我们艺术机构的事情。我们的艺术机构必须反映社区是什么，你知道，有时我们看不到这一点，人们不觉得与此有认同感，这就是为什么他们没有机会或不想去那里，因为古典音乐是精英主义的，我没有机会去那里。但当你把古典音乐，例如，带到
community, they feel that, you know, they are listened and they are important. So you are, it's a transformation. I believe that it's a beautiful transformation and we are in the right place. And Sean, I don't want to open up a bigger conversation, but it goes to your question about or why is it that governments, whether it's federal or state or municipal, whatever, cut funding to the arts and because it goes anytime you fund something like that, anytime you educate people, people in power are very threatened by that because education is a threat and the only thing you can do is to hold them down and the only thing that can free people from poverty, et cetera and their condition, art is one of those things, the arts are one of those things that can and education,
社区时，他们感觉到，你知道，他们被倾听了，他们很重要。所以你，这是一种转变。我相信这是一种美丽的转变，我们在正确的地方。肖恩，我不想开启一个更大的对话，但这回到了你的问题，关于为什么政府，无论是联邦、州还是市政，无论什么，削减对艺术的资助，因为每当你资助这样的事情，每当你教育人们，当权者就会感到非常受到威胁，因为教育是一种威胁，你唯一能做的就是压制他们，而唯一能让人们摆脱贫困等及其处境的东西，艺术就是其中之一，艺术是其中之一，可以
that can allow people to rise up. I believe in utopias, you know, I believe in because I'm a result of a crazy dream that have these men. These men have only nine people in front of him, nine young people, and he said, we will multiply this for millions. This was Maestro José Antonio Breuin Venezuela in 1975. And then now you have, we have Yola, we have a system in Sweden, we have the same program in different parts of the world, you know, to use music for social change. Yeah, it's incredible. And I've heard you say that before that you want to use music to change society. And I think, you know, we were talking about John Williams before, dare I say, I think you're accomplishing for Los Angeles and the world, what John Williams did, well, you know,
让人们崛起。我相信乌托邦，你知道，我相信，因为我是这个男人疯狂梦想的结果。这个男人面前只有九个人，九个年轻人，他说，我们将把这乘以数百万。这就是1975年在委内瑞拉的何塞·安东尼奥·阿布雷乌大师。现在你有，我们有YOLA，我们在瑞典有El Sistema，我们在世界不同地方有同样的计划，你知道，利用音乐进行社会变革。是的，这太不可思议了。我以前听你说过，你想用音乐改变社会。我认为，你知道，我们之前在谈论约翰·威廉姆斯，我敢说，我认为你正在为洛杉矶和世界实现约翰·威廉姆斯所做的，嗯，你知道，
with the Boston Pops and the world, which is making classical music popular. And, you know, through things that you're doing and, you know, programs like Yola and commissioning new works from new composers. And so, you know, in my eyes, it's a nice, I'm going to get a groan from my cohorts here, but it's a nice passing of the baton from John Williams to you, if you will. You're keeping the classical genre alive and kicking in and making people get inspired and want to explore more. And so, please don't ever stop doing that. Yeah. And I just, it's still, you can still feel in this city how exciting it is that you chose here to be and please don't ever leave. I mean, keep spreading that wealth that you're doing
与波士顿大众管弦乐团和世界一起，那就是让古典音乐流行起来。而且，你知道，通过你正在做的事情，你知道，像YOLA这样的项目，以及委托新作曲家创作新作品。所以，你知道，在我眼里，这是一个很好的，我会从我的同僚那里得到抱怨，但这是一个很好的从约翰·威廉姆斯到你的接力棒传递，如果你愿意的话。你让古典音乐流派保持活力，并激励人们想要探索更多。所以，请永远不要停止这样做。是的。我只是，你仍然可以在这个城市感受到你选择在这里是多么令人兴奋，请永远不要离开。我的意思是，继续传播你正在做的财富
around the world in a very, you know, considerably cheap way. You know, you're not distributing wealth monetarily, you're distributing wealth as you were talking about culturally. It's a very efficient and affordable way in which to do it, to empower and to enrich people that are less fortunate. And it is a very generous thing that you're doing. And we are proud as Los Angelinos to call you our own, at least temporarily. I hope you make it a long, long time now. Yeah, I'm an Angelino for all life. Yeah, good, good. All right. Well, we love you, pal. Thanks for coming on. No, thank you. Thank you for letting me be here and have fun with you. Thank you very much.
在世界各地，以一种非常，你知道，相当廉价的方式。你知道，你不是在金钱上分配财富，你是在分配财富，正如你所谈到的，在文化上。这是一种非常有效和负担得起的方式，去赋予和丰富那些不太幸运的人。这是你正在做的非常慷慨的事情。作为洛杉矶人，我们很自豪能称你为我们的一员，至少是暂时的。我希望你能待很长很长一段时间。是的，我终身都是洛杉矶人。是的，好，好。好吧，我们爱你，伙计。谢谢你来。不，谢谢你。谢谢你让我来到这里，和你一起玩得很开心。非常感谢。
Just so you know, I know I put it out there about 10 times already, but it is my dream to do something with you one day. Oh, that we will do. Be sure. I would hope I would do something crazy. I would love it. Don't give him your number. All right. Thank you, my dears. Take care. Thank you, my friends.
只是让你知道，我知道我已经说了大约10次了，但有一天和你一起做点什么是我梦想。哦，那我们一定会做的。肯定。我希望我能做点疯狂的事情。我会喜欢的。别给他你的号码。好吧。谢谢你们，亲爱的。保重。谢谢你们，我的朋友们。
Pleasure to meet you. Thank you, Gustavo. Bye-bye. Bye-bye now. Bye. That was, I'm just, I'm glad the listener couldn't see my stupid grinning face all the way through that. I just, I'm such a dork for classical music. And he is. I love that you are.
很高兴见到你。谢谢你，古斯塔沃。再见。再见。再见。那是，我只是，我很高兴听众看不到我整个过程中那张愚蠢的傻笑脸。我只是，我真是个古典音乐书呆子。他也是。我喜欢你是。
I would have. Oh my God. And you know, the one thing I wanted to ask him, but I didn't think of the question until the end of it, and he was wrapping up in such a beautiful, eloquent way as were you. I've always wondered, and you might know the answer to this, why when a conductor makes an arm gesture, it is always a beat before the music happens. In other words, you know, they're setting a tempo and it's never right on when you want the music to happen. It's just before. Why is that?
我会的。天哪。你知道，有一件事我想问他，但我直到最后才想到这个问题，而他正在以一种美丽、雄辩的方式结束，你也是。我一直很好奇，你可能知道这个答案，为什么当指挥做一个手臂动作时，它总是在音乐发生前的一拍。换句话说，你知道，他们设定了一个节奏，它从来不是在你想要音乐发生的时候。它就在之前。为什么是这样？
I think, and I may be wrong, but I've had that question before. I think it's because that's the way the brain works. So you don't want to be right on it because that's already too late. Got it. And maybe it gives them chance to like peek at the sheet music and then. Right. And you see it, we should have had Neil Tyson for that because it's light is faster than sound. So you see it and then the sound comes because it's slower.
我想，我可能错了，但我以前遇到过这个问题。我想这是因为大脑的工作方式。所以你不想正好在那个点上，因为那已经太晚了。明白了。也许这给了他们机会去偷看乐谱，然后。对。你看到了，我们本应该请尼尔·泰森来回答这个问题，因为光比声音快。所以你看到了，然后声音才传来，因为它更慢。
That's why. Right. Are you being serious? No, I'm not being serious. Sean, shut the fuck up guys. This is great that we didn't fuck up. I'm so glad you didn't embarrass us more. This is what I love. Burl lives, Ray Tovan, Jonas Brothers, wondering what the chemistry between Broden and Bonnie Hunt and Charles Groden, did you believe that there were.
这就是原因。对。你是认真的吗？不，我不是认真的。肖恩，闭嘴吧，伙计们。我们没有搞砸真是太好了。我很高兴你没有让我们更尴尬。这就是我所爱的。伯尔·艾夫斯，雷·托万，乔纳斯兄弟，想知道布罗登和邦妮·亨特以及查尔斯·格罗登之间的化学反应，你相信有吗。
All right, guys. Well, that was great. Thanks for joining. Sean, great, great, great guess. Sean, I don't know if that guess can be beat. Well done. Let's try. Will and I will be competing for the silver from here on out. All right, guys, we'll talk to you later, Jason.
好吧，伙计们。嗯，那太棒了。谢谢加入。肖恩，很棒，很棒，很棒的猜测。肖恩，我不知道那个猜测是否能被超越。干得好。让我们试试。威尔和我从现在开始将争夺银牌。好吧，伙计们，我们稍后再聊，杰森。
I know you love this. Ready, Will? Yeah, I guess I'm ready. We'll talk to you later. Bye. So terrible. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我知道你喜欢这个。准备好了吗，威尔？是的，我想我准备好了。我们稍后再聊。再见。太糟糕了。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。